always make sure that your product or
your service is of the highest quality
you could ever make it because you do
not want to be you do not want to be in
the selling business successful people
do all the things that unsuccessful
people don't want to do if I had email I
would be inundated I choose not to have
email or ever turn a computer on need
motivation watch a top 10 of belief
nation what's up at 7 my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from selling newspapers and
Christmas cards at age 9 just to support
his family and being told by his
teachers that he would never succeed at
anything in life to becoming a self-made
billionaire and philanthropist he's John
Paul DeJoria
and here's my take on his top 10 rules
success vol 2 enjoy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one be prepared for rejection the
best advice I could give is number one
be prepared for a lot of rejection if
you're ready for rejection of people say
no I don't want it no it's not gonna
work no this is crazy whatever if you're
prepared for it it's not gonna let you
down
learn from your failures I had a lot of
failures along the way even with my
patron and Paul Mitchell but we learn
from those things then we get a lot
better rule number 2 my personal
favorite be in the reorder business any
business you're in whether it's a
service or whether it's a product or
anybody you work with that has a product
or a service always make sure that your
product or your service
is of the highest quality you could ever
make it because you do not want to be
you do not want to be in the selling
business you want to be in the reorder
business granted you've got to tell
somebody what your idea is and you learn
how it's going to cure something they
may need but the quality has to be so
good that after that they want to
reorder it or if it's a one-time item
tell friends about it and if people
think and whatever they're doing in life
in the reorder business whether it's
with a personal relationship whatever
you see right now
your to see again and again and again
it's going to enhance they'll be ups and
downs here's my product it's so darn
good you're going to use it
we started Paul Mitchell we have no
money but we knew our product was so
darn good that we got enhance of enough
people they're gonna be reordering it
because it was that quality service the
same way rule number three go the extra
mile
successful people do all the things that
unsuccessful people don't want to do and
if you have to work Saturdays and
Sundays or later night or get up early
in the morning just do it when I started
John Paul Mitchell Systems there are few
hundred bucks in my pocket I should live
in my car for the first couple of weeks
and that $700 went a long long way rule
number four be a hard worker
I worked most of my life in high school
there was Stewart's cleaners after
school would go there I would put the
drape on the hanger the sleeve on the
hanger and the janitor of all the
cleaners clean everything up I worked
for $1 in a quarter an hour
the only reason was a dollar and a
quarter in hours because the steward had
to pay that it was required by law or
he'd be giving me 50 cents an hour it
was a very tight very tight wad guy so I
came in one day after school and he says
to me to go to work he says Johnny come
here want to talk to us okay taja stirry
says Johnny I was upstairs yesterday and
I napped after I finished working I was
tired and I dropped my watch on the
floor I put on the tape went on the
floor and went down I picked it up and I
noticed under the cot I was lying on
there was no dust
I moved the cot there was no dust I
looked behind the filing cabinets there
was no dust or whatsoever zero dust you
really are a great janitor I said it's
my job to do what I do when I do it not
when someone else is looking tie this
guy in the world gave me a 25 cent raise
two dollar fifty where I went to high
school a highest-paid kid and maybe a
dolphin the neighborhood we have a lot
of a in those days what it was was if
people if humans can't imagine doing
what you have to do when nobody is
watching you your doings if someone is
right there watching you and in your
free time you're not trying to elongate
something you're doing what you should
do without people watching you do it
rule number five be positive so of all
the things in the world that you could
say are like the secrets that being
positive
one of the main things that people need
to do how did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place they move
along in life faster they're veteran and
people want to be around these people I
mean too often people gossip the one
gossip person wants to be around the
other person that gossips but they don't
realize when you gossip you're saying
something heard about somebody else
you're telling everybody what if part of
it was wrong you to go out and tell
every person you told this oh I'm sorry
it was wrong tell everybody you told
it's not going to happen so it seems you
learn about don't gossip don't belittle
people if you don't have to god please
don't try and look at the positive angle
what good could come out of something
and that possum nests is gonna make you
live longer happier and wake up in the
morning happy not oh my god I gotta go
to work I can't wait til I get home I
want to retire because people are not
positive they were not happy and what
happens they retire they hate their job
they retire three or four years later
their debts they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people encourage positiveness if you
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot
man move or just try and do something
different change your life being
positive and a positive attitude is find
something positive and something bad
makes you look for solutions when I was
down and out okay who all pop bottles
let's get the pop bottles cash em in
rule number six just be it's all in the
mindset when you get up in the morning
you do what you normally do I would
eventually say a lot of you here
probably turn on your cellphone's your
computers and what's the latest email
what's the latest text that comes in you
start your day off like that
that's your mindset try this get up in
the morning do whatever you have to do
don't turn the computer on don't turn
the TV on go right back to bed again
either lay there or sit there and just
bring the universe
to you here's how you do it you just be
it's virtually impossible when you first
do it
because the thousand thoughts come
through your head were human beings so
what you do is your city in bed look at
the wall look at the off TV set look at
the ceiling look at the door look at
something in the room to get your
attention and just look at it and just
be for a couple of minutes not 10
minutes not 20 minutes not two days just
be when your mind wanders find another
spot in the room to look at so you're
back in present time even for a couple
of minutes now go about your day don't
think about what you're gonna do for
that split few minutes
you're now becoming part of a universe
which is also part of global thinking
rule number seven pay attention to the
vital few if I had email I would be
inundated I choose not to have email or
ever turn a computer on now all my
companies are state of the art
technologically advanced if I want
something printed out it's printed out
for me
but I do this out of choice I'd rather
make a phone call to you or write you a
letter and communicate the way you
deserve to be communicated with and no
disrespecting people on email and I'd be
so inundated my gosh I'd be on that
computer all day long I prefer to have
that personal touch and it seems to work
with all the companies I have that I'm
quite active in but I have great
presence running most of them thank God
a very bless our right to take care of
the details but I'm still hands on in
many many of the businesses here and
it's I can work better that way and it
goes down to this pay attention to the
vital few ignore the trivia many if I
had email no disrespect there be a lot
of trivia on there I be answering I try
and pay attention to the vital few and
ignore the trivial what do you
differentiate those those two categories
to be like where would let's say you're
president be and where would like the
head of a sales division be are they are
two sides of that equation know what it
is is if it's one of my companies you
could call me directly but people know
call me directly if you have to but
don't bother me with something someone
else can handle then they do it it works
really really fine works really well but
what's important would be obviously
presence of company anyone that's
involved with me either Phil
entropically the main people feeling
properly are the main people my business
is or places or countries I want to
reach out to of the head of a country
will
call me I'll call them right back you
know things are very very significant
insignificant our I'll give you an
example in my life it has been
significant I'm hit up every months for
hundreds of requests send me a hundred
dollars send me two million dollars you
have all the money share it with me and
I just I don't even touch it I can't
I'm swarmed I do so much philanthropy
now everyone expects that whether it's a
two million dollar mortgage or hey I
want to start a new business send me
fifty thousand dollars because you have
money I don't that people should do it
well that's not true
I spend millions on philanthropic work
but I do it through our foundation where
it really makes sense not where I have
to go through it all so my question is
how do you begin to set up that system
so that you have the and I'll call it a
luxury in some ways of communicating as
you see fit when you see fit with those
key decision-makers well for starters
I'm the chairman of the board okay of
the major company so I know detail
what's going on from the chairman of the
board's point of view I also know that
the people that I've hired can do what
they're doing much better than I can and
I know what I need to know and so do
they so they could pick up the phone and
call me JP we just did this or look what
we're doing here I also attend meetings
on a regular basis to see where we're at
and where we're going and meet with
marketing people meet with promotional
people meet with our educational people
sports marketing people to get a
hands-on feel for what we're doing where
we're going and those really important
meetings Isen and to help make the
decisions rule number eight treat people
nicely when I work for other companies
some of them not mentioning names were
so bad they would treat people the old
way I'm the boss here's what you're
gonna do because I'm the boss right or
there were times for example when maybe
had a dollar for lunch II can't get a
lot for a dollar so I just knew that
that's how I was and if I had a company
that I had a control of my gosh
everyone's gonna be treated the way I
wanted to be treated so the minute we
could afford it everyone had free lunch
whether they had money or not you have
free lunch we pay for it for you
car pool will pay for that so we started
doing things for people that I wish
happened to me maybe that's part of fate
maybe because a lot of things along the
way weren't so good that
things started getting good it was so
easy for me to share with our people so
easy to do that people sometimes don't
save money as soon as we possibly could
afford it we started profit sharing
where at the end of every year and we'll
take that profit sharing and put in a
retirement fund for you it's yours it's
yours if your so many years it goes with
you no matter where you go
but it's yours it's your money that's
really incredible and how much do you
think that that sort of Golden Rule
approach has fed into your ridiculously
low turnover rate which is literally
almost unprecedented I mean that's crazy
I try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly the
way I would have wanted to be treated
I'm happy with my people I realized my
people aren't the company if my people
go my god the company goes people are
your company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why and because
you treat people this way and we'd love
them you walk in our company it's love
if you go to the front desk here in
Century City this girl just has the
biggest smile say hi welcome to John
Paul Mitchell Systems she loves oh what
she does our big problem is we don't
have turnover we have so many people on
to work for us and the thing is you
gotta wait for somebody that died now as
we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously at a time sure and we're
pretty big now because we're in 96
countries that's how you take care of
people anywhere in the world
you don't boss them around you include
them what you're doing rule number 9
help others growing up we grew up with
little to no money but we didn't know it
we had a blast growing up because we
know we didn't have anything and it was
great
was okay through a lot of moments of my
life that were very beneficial and I
think that influenced my life I think
one great example is at six years old my
mother told my brother and I take a dime
put into this man ringing a bell it was
a Salvation Army and we had nothing but
she said guys we could afford 10 cents
this year Salvation Army's for people
have no money and no home and no food
and that's all we could give but
remember twice as long as you live
there's always somebody that needs it
more than you do try donate a little
we can afford a dime but at least we're
making a donation and rule number 10 the
last one before some special bonus clips
for you is B in Eagle when God created
this planet he created up several
species now if you're an atheist it's
okay call it the force let me just say
God for now setup said God the forest
god the forest let's just say God right
now God creates the planet Earth and
first of all he creates which a lot of
people and different organizations want
a perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taking care of there's no
extra imagination necessary because all
can be given to you so he creates the
oyster eases oyster I'm giving you a
free house to live in I'm calling it a
shell I'm gonna put at the bottom of the
ocean to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the foods you
want protection everything you want the
perfectly taken care of while you're in
your measly little life as an oyster but
you're not gonna go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom the ocean
but you're totally got your free food
free clothing for everything one then
God created something called the Eagle
Eagle whole different species Eagle you
want a house you go out and build it
gate the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed its young did you know the
Eagle fails 95% of the time a total
failure it's so big and cumbersome that
when it comes upon its prey
they're wild they should off in a
different direction and it misses 5% of
the time it succeeds and what does
succeed to do it succeeded to being the
strongest bird in the sky the only one
that we know of anywhere in the world
that could fly into the thermals of a
hurricane and ride them to have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
any where it wants anywhere it wants ya
Gamble's it does
on its own but it goes wherever it wants
now that Eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of America and also on the flag
of many many countries you wouldn't be
in this room right now if you weren't
Eagles don't only imagine start doing it
thank you peace love and happiness all
of you thank you very much
[Music]
now I've got two very special bonus
clips from John Paul DeJoria on finding
what you love to do and knowing your
power but before that my question the
day for you is I want you to complete
this sentence I am an eagle because I
blank
leaving the comments below look forward
to hear what you have to say thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much loved see you soon and enjoyed
the bonus clips
in life we don't always know what we
want to do I didn't always know but in
life we find out quickly what we don't
want to do so we got me try and look at
what it is you want to do you don't have
to be the boss what is that you enjoy
being around what makes you get up and
saying I can't wait to hear the office
we have people Paul Mitchell working at
7 8 o'clock at night they don't have to
one day I walked in there was 10 of them
what are you doing here we want to
finish our projects you don't have to we
all went out to dinner I just like God
because they love what they're doing so
one is find out what you want to do the
majority of people wait for the masses
to do something when the masses do
something they join in and they join on
board but they forget that the masses
are made up of individuals those
individuals each in a zone is extremely
powerful if they realize how powerful
they are if you realize how powerful you
are and what you could do to make a huge
difference that affects everybody around
you if you knew your power and what you
could achieve
we wouldn't be outsourcing jobs as a
politician say to overseas countries we
be more than adequate to do it ourselves
here because we be 2 3 4 times more
efficient it's all about imagining and
doing believing yourself raise your
standard Apple at the core this core
value is that passion
[Music]
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's suppose to mean I don't ever
give up I'd have to be dead or
completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details